buenas tardes si se trata de suela
braverman ella es la fiscal general del
país acaba de ser retirada de esta
campaña de esta candidatura de la
carrera por reemplazar a boris johnson
como primer ministro británico obtuvo
menos votos así que quedan cinco
candidatos en esta pelea liderados por
rich y sunat el ex ministro de finanzas
que ha obtenido 101 votos ha empezado a
mostrarse su mayoría también penny
guardan listas que me va de lo que es la
sorpresa de esta elección it on again
hat aunque por supuesto todavía estamos
en una etapa muy inicial de esta carrera
por reemplazar al primer ministro si
vamos viendo poco a poco las tendencias
de quienes que hicieran los diputados
británicos que fueran los finalistas
ricci sinac y penny morgan pero por
supuesto todavía falta mucho y
finalmente serán las bases del partido
unas 180.000 200.000 personas las que
tomarán la decisión de quién será el
reemplazo de boris johnson
mañana no habrá
eliminatoria no habrá
de eliminación pero si el lunes se
eliminará también a la persona que
obtenga menos votos entonces quedarán
cuatro candidatos y así durante toda la
próxima semana hasta que queden los dos
finalistas luego de estas dos personas
iniciaron una gira por todo el país para
tratar de conquistar votos entonces el
nuevo primer ministro su nombre será
revelado el 5 de septiembre